trigger action plan that's what you need
power
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show my guest
today is william mccaskill that's m a c
a s k i l l you can find him on twitter
at will mccaskill will is an associate
professor in philosophy at the
university of oxford at the time of his
appointment he was the youngest
associate professor of philosophy in the
world a forbes 30 under 30 social
entrepreneur he also co-founded the
non-profits giving what we can the
center for effective altruism and the y
combinator backed 80 000 hours which
together have moved over 200 million
dollars to effective charities you can
find my 2015 conversation with will at
tim dot blog slash will just a quick
side note we probably won't spend too
much time on this but in that 2015
conversation we talked about existential
risk and the number one highlight was
pathogens although we didn't use the
word pandemic certainly that was perhaps
a prescient discussion based on the type
of research the many types of research
that will does his new book is what we
owe the future it is blurbed by several
guests of this podcast including
neuroscientist and author sam harris who
wrote quote no living philosopher has
had a greater impact upon my ethics than
will mccaskill dot dot dot this is an
altogether thrilling and necessary book
and quote you can find him online
william mccaskill.com
will nice to see you again thanks for
making the time thanks for having me
back on it's delight
and i thought we would start with
some
say warm-up questions to get people
right into some details of how you think
the information you consume
and so on and so forth so we're going to
begin with a few questions i often
reserve for the end of conversations we
covered some of the other rapid fire
questions in the last conversation for
people who want a lot on your bio how
you ended up being the youngest
associate professor philosophy in the
world at the time of your appointment
and so on they can listen to our first
conversation but we spoke about a few
books last time and i'd be curious
what is the book or what are the books
that you have given most as a gift
and
why
or
what are some books that have had a
great influence on you i know we talked
already about practical ethics by peter
singer and then super intelligence by
nick bostrom last time but do any other
books come to mind when i asked that
question yeah so here are a couple
one is the precipice by my colleague
toby ort who
i co-founded giving what we can with
back in 2009
and it's on the topic of existential
risks so i see it as a compliment to
my book what we are the future
and it details in
kind of quite beautiful pose and also
painstaking detail
some of the risks that we face as a
civilization
from the familiar asteroids to the less
familiar super volcanoes and to the
truly terrifying which i also discussed
in the book and
um discuss how we might try and handle
like artificial intelligence and
you know
engineered pathogens and engineered
pandemics
and it also just talks about you know
what we can do about them as well and so
i think it's just like absolutely
necessary a subject
we'll talk i guess a bunch about some of
those topics
as we get into
my work too
uh so i have like another kind of set of
books which are quite different but
they've had
some of the biggest impact on just the
background of my thinking
over the last few years
in very subtle ways and that's joe
heinrich's books the secret of our
success and the weirdest people in the
world and
joe heinrich is a kind of quantitative
anthropologist
at
harvard
and his first book is just why are
humans
the most powerful and ecologically
dominant species on the planet
and people often say like oh it's our
big brains and he's like no
brains are
several times the size of a chimpanzee's
brain but that's not the distinctive
thing the distinctive thing is that we
work together essentially we're capable
of cumulative cultural evolution where i
can learn something and then my children
will pick it up for me even if they
don't really understand why i'm doing it
and that means that the way humans
function it's not like a single brain
that's three times the size of a
chimpanzee it's tens of thousands of
brains all working in concert and now
millions of planes over many generations
and that's why
there's such a big gap between
like chimpanzee ability or intelligence
and human intelligence
it's not a scale-up of 3x it's a scale
up of 300 000. the hive mind of hominids
basically that's exactly right so on
this perspective humans are
not just another species that are like
weird and not hairy and particularly
sweaty and good at long-distance
learning aristotle commented that humans
of a rational animal and that's what
made them distinct from other animals
whereas actually we're just very sweaty
and that's one of our most distinctive
characteristics
and i like to think that i am therefore
the most human of humans because i'm the
sweatiest person i've met
so here's this book and that alone just
you know really blew my mind it really
made a big difference to how i
understand humans
and he has this other book the weirdest
people in the world which is about the
psychology in particular of
uh weird people western educated
industrialized rich and democratic
which are the subject of almost all
psychology experiments but they're not
representative at all of most cultures
in fact very unusual among most cultures
much more individualistic much more
willing to challenge authority
even perceive the world in slightly
different ways and the overall picture
you get from these two books
is an understanding of kind of human
behavior that's very different from the
kind of economic understanding of human
behavior as there were all these just
like self-interested agents going around
trying to kind of maximize profit for
ourselves
whereas on this vision it's like no
we're these cultural beings we have like
a vision for the world and we go and
like try and put that vision into the
world and that's what like the big fight
like the kind of big fights are about
and i think it has a much better
explanation of history but anyway i'll
stop there
when you said quantitative i think you
said quantitative anthropologists am i
hearing that correctly yeah that's
exactly about it what is a quantitative
anthropologist i know those two words
separately and i can i can pretend like
i understand what those mean together
but what does a quantitative
anthropologist do so you might know kind
of evolutionary biology
has these formal models of how kind of
genes evolve over time
[Music]
and you can i don't know it's hard to
make predictions within this field but
at least you have these like precise
formal methods that you like can start
to kind of understand what's going on in
terms of how organisms evolve
now it turns out you can do the same
thing but applied to cultures
i mean dawkins made this word meme very
famous and that kind of gets across the
right idea although it's not quite right
because
it's not like there's a single divisible
unit of culture
but nonetheless you can think of
different cultures kind of like
different species
and some are like more fit than others
so some are going to win out over time
and you can apply the same sort of like
formal methods that evolutionary
biologists use
to
study evolution of genetics to the
evolution of cultures as well
and johannes does that at least a little
bit
all right well i'll have to take a look
now
we were talking well we using the royal
we you we're talking about i suppose i
mentioned in passing existential risks
and threats
and
i have a number of questions
related to this not surprisingly but i
want to touch upon first perhaps an
unexpected insertion
i have in my notes here crime and
punishment by dostoyevsky as a book that
was important to you
and
i would like to know why that is the
case
so that book is actually what got me
into philosophy originally
back when i was about 15 i read it and i
was at a time
variance in literature i wanted to be a
poet and an author
and
it was via that that i learned about
this word philosophy and i realized that
like oh actually you can just tackle the
big ideas directly you don't need to go
via fiction
but i was also particularly in the time
in existentialist
philosophy
and
this is something that honestly like i
kind of still bear with me i'm kind of a
bit unusual in that
i often think to myself
could i justify my life now to my 15
year old self
and if the answer is no then i'm a bit
like oh what are you doing you're not
living up to
what earlier will would have wanted for
pleasant will
and the key thing i think for 15 year
old will who was inspired by
existentialism was living an authentic
life
and
i still find that
very
liberating and empowering and inspiring
so some of the things i do so for
example i've i give away most of my
income which is like a very unusual
thing to do and you might think
oh that's like a sacrifice that's making
my life worse but actually i find it
kind of empowering because it's like
i am making an autonomous decision i am
like not merely kind of following the
dictates of
what social convention is telling me to
do but i'm like reasoning about things
from first principles and then making a
decision that's like genuinely
authentically mine
and that was something
i hadn't particularly
pegged it to kind of acting morally when
i was 15 although to some extent but
that was something that really moved me
then
and
yeah honestly continues to move me today
so how would you just
for i i often say for the listeners out
there who may not be familiar but
honestly if i'm being honest with myself
i i have not studied existentialism and
i i hear certain names associated with
it so i can kind of fake it until i make
it and give it create the illusion i'll
be like ah you know kirkegaard i think
maybe uh this person that person but
what is
existentialism as it is portrayed in
crime and punishment
or conveyed
well i think one of the things i liked
about crime and punishment and
dostoevsky's work in particular
is that it kind of
at least is wrestling with
existentialism
so
and that can work can get used in
various ways
but here
one way of thinking about it is just
the world as it is like has no intrinsic
meaning
yeah and yet we are like placed into it
and have to make decisions
and that's this like absurd position to
be in
and
you can
create your own meaning out of that
through
like
radically free acts
like authentic genuine acts
and
dostoyevsky in his work
kind of wrestles between
like three positions i think
one is this like existentialist position
a second is just pure nihilism which is
just like actually literally if you take
it seriously like and there's no god
then everything is permitted there's no
reason to do anything
not even like reason creators don't
you know from yourself
and then third is this religious
position which i think he actually
ultimately endorses
and it's almost like
nihilism as
like a proof
like the rejection of nihilism like
therefore guarantees that you should be
like religious
qed yeah
exactly yeah well it's like
life is meaningless unless um god exists
and i'm now describing it slightly
pascalian terms but like you may as well
act as if there's a god that is giving
meaning to life
we're not going to spend a whole bunch
of time on it now but in our last
conversation we talked about pascal's
wager but also pascal's mugging if i
remember correctly yeah very good yeah
something along those lines so we won't
we won't take a side alley down into
pascal's mugging just now but i i said i
had two things i wanted to ask you about
the first was crown punishment which i
think we've covered
the second before we jump into
our longer conversation which will go
all over the place and i may ask still
some of the shorter questions
when people hear existential
threats when they hear super volcanoes
ai
man-made
pathogens etc i think that
there will likely be an apprehension
perhaps a a little
seizure of the breath for some people
listening who might think to themselves
my god this is just going to be audio
doom scrolling this is just going to
come away from this conversation
with higher blood pressure more cortisol
and
my impression of you in the time that
we've spent together is that you are
uh you are not nihilistic you are not
apathetic you are not pessimistic you're
quite the opposite of all of those
things in some respects
how do you do that
and
is that just well out of the box and
that's that's just how you came
programmed is there more to it and this
is this is i think a crux question
because i i don't
see in the people
say in my audience including those who
are very competent
effective action if they don't have some
degree of optimism
or
uh
belief that they can exert change right
so could you just speak to that because
i know i also succumb to just getting
waterboarded bad news all day from
around the world i'm like shh i can't do
i can't
i cannot put a salve onto all of this
for all of these people and it can be
overwhelming so how would you how would
you respond to that uh i think there's
two things um that motivate this one is
just the desire to actually make the
world better and then second i'll call
low standards so um
[Laughter]
on the first side um i mean when i first
so you know age 21
and i'm like man i'm about to really
start my life
i'm trying to look for like i want to
act morally i'm trying to look for
different causes
i bounce into a lot of kind of classic
you know the sorts of classic causes
that you'd find for someone socially
motivated in a college campus like
vegetarian society
some you know left-wing politics climate
change stuff
and i found there was very little in the
way of action there was an awful lot of
like guilt and an awful lot of talking
about problems
but not that much in terms of like hey
here are the solutions this is how you
can actually make the world better and
this is what we should do
but if you actually care about what
making wanting to make the world better
and that's the key motivation
the size of a problem and like really
thinking about suffering i mean it can
be important especially if it's
motivating you but the ultimate thing is
just what you do
something could be the worst problem in
the world but if there's nothing you can
do then it's just not relevant for the
purpose of action
and
that therefore really makes me think in
the first instance
always about okay well what's the
difference we can make
not like how scary are things or how bad
are things but instead like how much of
a difference can we make and there
that's like very positive so in the last
podcast
you know we were focusing in particular
on global health and development and
what's the difference you can make there
well if you're a middle class member of
a rich country it's on the order of
saving dozens hundreds maybe even
thousands of lives over the course of
your life if you put your mind to it
that's huge
now we're talking about existential
risks and the long-term future of
humanity what's the difference you can
make
you can be you can play a part in being
pivotal in putting humanity onto a
better trajectory for not just centuries
but for thousands millions or even
billions of years
the amount of good that you can do is
like truly enormous you can have like
cosmic significance
that's inspiring and so
yeah when you think about the difference
you can make rather than just like
focusing on the magnitude of the
problems i think there's every reason
for optimism
and then the second aspect i've said was
low standards
which is just you know what's a world
that you should be sad about what's a
world you should be happy with well
in my own case i think like
look if i came into the world and when i
leave it the world is neither better nor
worse
that's like zero i should be indifferent
about that
if i can make it a bit better as in
virtue of my existence hey that's pretty
good
the better the bet like the more good i
can do on top of that the better
and i think i have made it much better
like
you know i'm not zero i'm like positive
and so all of the additional good that i
potentially do feels like a bonus
and so similarly with humanity when i
look to the future what's the level at
which i'm like ah it's indifferent
that's where just like the amount of
happiness and suffering in the future
kind of cancel out and relative to that
i think the future is going to be
amazing like
already i think the world today is like
much better than if it didn't exist
and i think it's gonna be a lot better
in the future like even just the
progress we've made over the last few
hundred years
people today have like far far better
lives if you extrapolate that out just
you know a few hundred years more let
alone thousands of years
then there's at least a good chance that
we could have a future where
everyone lives not just as well as the
best people off alive today but maybe
tens hundreds thousands of times better
yeah i mean kings kings a few hundred
years ago didn't have running water
right
no they didn't they were air
conditioning they didn't have anesthetic
no antibiotics oops if they were gay
they had to keep it secret they could
barely travel yeah lots of things we
easily take for granted which
we can we can come back to because it
may be related but
why don't we take
60 to 120 seconds just for you to
explain effective altruism your name is
often associated just so we have a
definition of terms and people have some
idea of the scope
and meaning of effective altruism since
you're considered
one of the creators or co-creators of
this entire movement if you wouldn't
mind just explaining that briefly and
that way people will have at least that
as a landmark as we go forward
effective altruism is a philosophy and a
community that's about trying to figure
out how can we do as much good as
possible with the time and money we have
and then taking action on that basis so
putting those ideas into practice to i
actually tried to make the world better
as effectively as possible whether
that's through our donations with our
careers with how we vote with our
consumption decisions just with our
entire lives
what have been some of the outcomes
of that
yeah so you know i've been promoting
these ideas along with others
for over 12 years now um we've raised
well over um or moved well over the
billion dollars to the most effective
causes
so that means if we take just one
charity that we've raised money for
against malaria foundation
we've protected over 400 million
people mainly children
from malaria
and statistically that means we've saved
about 100 000 lives
or maybe a little more uh which is you
know the size of a small town about the
size of oxford
and that's just one charity there's
several more within global health and
development i think
in terms of
other course areas that we focused on
within animal health and welfare
hundreds of millions of
hens are no longer in cages because of
corporate cage free campaigns that we've
helped to fund
and then within the field of existential
risks there are
you know it's not as easy to say oh
we've done this concrete thing this
thing would have killed us all but we
avoided it but we have helped make ai
safety a much more mainstream field of
the search people taking the potential
benefits but also the risks from ai like
much more seriously than they were
we
are also like
have invested a lot in pattern pandemic
preparedness measures again it's kind of
still early sages but some of the
technology there or things i think have
a really promising
potential to action at least
making sure that covert 19 is the last
pandemic we ever have
one of the many things i appreciate
about you and also
broadly speaking many people in the
effective altruism
community slash movement is
the taking of a systematic approach to
not just defining but questioning
assumptions and
quantitatively
looking at how you can
do good not just feel good
if that makes sense and it seems obvious
to anyone who's in the community but the
vast majority of
of
philanthropy
or charity broadly speaking is done
without that type of
approach from what i can tell and
it's it's really worth
taking a closer look for those people
listening are there just a few urls
you'd like to mention for people who'd
like to dig into that and then we can
then we can move into
some of the
more current questions
for sure so if you're interested in how
to use your career to make the world
better then eighty thousand hours.org is
you know a terrific place to go i'm a
co-founder of that organization gives
in-depth career advice and one-on-one
um career coaching as well
if you're interested in donating some of
your money then giving what we can.org
encourages people to take a giving
pledge uh typically 10 of one's income
or more
it's a great way to live
if you're interested in donating to
effective charities then givewell.org is
the single best place for donating to
global health and development charities
that's givewell.org
there's also the effective altruism
funds or ea funds that allow you to
donate within animal welfare and
existential risks
and
kind of promotion of these ideas as well
all right a few more calisthenics then
we're going to go into the heavy lifting
the max the max squats of
long termism
right
here we go in the last say five years
you can pick the time frame but recent
history what new belief behavior or
habit has most improved your life
i think the biggest one of all and this
was really big during
writing the book which was this you know
enormous challenge it was like my main
focus for two years over the course of
the pandemic
was evening check-ins
with
an employee of mine who also functioned
a bit like a productivity coach so every
evening i would uh set deadlines for the
next day both input and output so input
would be how many hours of tracked
lighting i would do where going to the
bathroom did not count
a really big day would be six hours
sometimes very occasionally i'd kind of
get more than that
and also output goals as well so i'd say
i will have drafted this section or
these sections or i will done such and
such
i would also normally make some other
commitments as well such as you know how
much time do i spend looking at reddit
on my phone
how much caffeine am i allowed to drink
do i exercise things like this
and laura
pomerius who's doing it is wonderful and
the nicest person ever and she just
never beat me up about this
but i would beat myself up but it would
make me it was incredibly effective at
making sure i was just like actually
doing things because i like many others
find writing it's like hard it's like
hard to get motivated it's hard to keep
going
and
sometimes i don't know i'd have gotten
drunk the night before let's say and it
was a sunday and normally you just it
would be a light off the whole day i
think like oh no it should be so
embarrassing at 7 p.m to have to tell
laura like yeah i didn't do any work
because i got smashed
and so instead i would feel hungover and
i would just keep typing away and that
was just huge i mean i think it
increased my productivity
i don't know it feels like 20 or 25 or
something just from these like 10-minute
check-ins every day
so these were 10-minute check-ins seven
days a week what was the cadence i was
working six days a week so
but yeah if she was doing something else
at the weekend we wouldn't check in
right so the format would be
walk me through ten minutes would be the
first five minutes
here's how i measured up to what i
committed and here's what i'm doing next
exactly so it would be a review of the
day
so yeah did i hit my input goal my
output goal how much caffeine did i
think did i exercise and then also like
was i getting any migraines or back pain
which are two kind of ongoing issues for
my productivity
next would be a discussion of what i
would try to do the following day
and interestingly you might think of a
productivity coach as someone who's like
you know really putting your like nose
to the grindstone
whereas with laura that's kind of the
opposite because my problem is that i
beat myself up too much
so she's like luring e.t out of the
closet with the reese's pieces exactly
candy
yeah so i would be like oh i got so
little done today so i'm gonna have to
just have a 12-hour day tomorrow or
something or like i'll work through the
night or something like that and she's
like that doesn't make any sense like
you know we've tracked this before and
when you try and do this maybe you get
like an hour of extra work where you
feel horrible for days afterwards
and
so she would be very good at like
countering
[ __ ] that my brain would be
saying basically
so couple things caffeine
what were your parameters on caffeine
like what were the
limitations or minimums i don't know how
you said it on caffeine and then how did
you choose
this
employee specifically for this and why
so caffeine i mean i think a big thing
is just if i drink too much i'm likely
to get a migraine so i set my limit at
three espressos worth so about 180
milligrams of caffeine and i'm very
sensitive so it's like 180 is legitimate
for a sensitive person exactly so that's
like the max that i do whereas a double
expresso is fine
but then it's like shading in between
i'll be like really cautious about and
then how did i choose this person i
think it's like a very subtle thing
the kind of rapport or
personal fit you have with someone who
can be a good coach
where
she kind of knew me well enough that she
knew the ways to like push me around and
was like
yeah kind of the combination of like
maybe i call it friendly pushiness or
something was
is like perfect
you know it could be very easy to go
along on either side of that line
all right sounds like i need an evening
checking all right
who's my who is my victim going to be
all right maybe we can spy it
well
i know i know i know it's i know it's
four in the morning but i had to call
you for my evening check-in
we're in different time zones for people
who may not have picked up on the that
is not a new jersey accent that will has
okay comment
sidebar on
low back pain i know this came up in our
last conversation have you not found
anything to help and i may have some
suggestions if you would like
suggestions but have you found anything
to help actually i've almost completely
fixed it so it was just i mean i was
working you know just sitting in a chair
especially you know pandemic and like a
book for
like eight hours a day but um there's
actually only one period that i started
getting lower back pain i remember in
our conversation you recommended me
these boots that so they could hang
upside down
and i did buy them and i confess i never
use them so i'm sorry tim
adherence failure no that's a failure my
recommendation if it's not going to be
used it doesn't make any sense for me to
recommend it
but what i did do
in the end i just developed my own
workout routine
where i got advice from physios and so
on um i talked to like loads of doctors
in general people just aren't really
engaging with what your problems are and
like self-experimentation i think was
just better
the other thing is just all of this
takes loads of time and like if you're a
time-tested individual
so i mean firstly the advice is often
like geared towards like old people so
it's like very like easy stretches or
like basic work
movement that most people aren't doing
and then secondly it's like
man you want to do all of this it's like
two hours or something like i can do
this more efficiently
so i developed my own routine which
involves
standing on a bosu ball so all in a bosu
ball okay i've got two free weights i do
a squat i'm sitting in like squat
position as the resting position that's
really good because it stretches your
hip flexors
and for those people who can't see well
he's got his hands in front of his chest
yeah imagine like a prairie dog but
really i think what that symbolizes is
he has the dumbbells in front of his
chest like a goblet squat if people know
what that is yeah exactly with my legs
wide kind of neat elbows in between your
knees so that your legs are kind of
slide out like that and you'll feel a
stretch on your hip flexors so cultures
that squat to sit
actually experience lower weights of
back pain so that was the kind of
inspiration there and then from there
standing up squat
do a bicep curl up into a
shoulder press
go down then
dead lift going into an upside low and
then that's kind of what and that's all
in a bosu ball and the thoughts here are
like strengthening your entire kind of
anterior pelvic chain so i think my
hypothesis was like why was i getting
this it's because i was on a
an idiot young male who was like why
would you work anything out apart from
your beach muscles what would be the
point of that
and that like majorly distorted my
posture
and so
i would do that
so kind of one of them every 20 seconds
in like two sets of ten minutes
and then that combined in also with core
work so plank in particular
really just i think sorted things out
because it's all about just like
you know had just bad posture for
25 years
made worse by like very poor focus at
the gym and so it's like this long
process of reconfiguring your body so
that it's like
it makes more sense
and in particular as we talked about had
anterior pelvic tilt so my my gut stuck
out my pelvis was too far forward and so
then it's like your glutes tearing that
back and then
stretching out your hip flexors yeah oh
and i invented my own stretch as well
so um
for the listeners who don't know um i
actually i was previously married and
i took a different name took my wife's
grandmother's maiden name so my name
wasn't always mccaskill it used to be
crouch and so i named this stretch the
will crouch in honor of my former self
but it involves standing and um hooking
your you stand up you hook your foot um
into your two hands
and then like press out like kind of
extend your leg but pushing against your
two hands
and
that
stretches out
this
muscle
that is
goes all the way from your kind of
pelvis up your back and i've not found
any other stretch that stretches that
particular muscle and that was the one
that was like really causing all the
pain
so you do this standing
i guess it's standing that's right yeah
it's like a kid and play dance move okay
so people may just i'll i'll put my
liability hat on i'll just say maybe
start on the ground to try this one
so you don't get your foot stuck and
topple over like a
you know uh an army figurine onto your
head but yeah yes i can see how that
would work anyone would say that i'm not
a professional um
workout coach
i can't wait for the will crouch youtube
instructional fitness series
so i did take on this role in the early
stages of the pandemic the house i was
in i would go outside
every every lunch at 1 p.m and put on my
best scottish accent and i'd be like
right yui pricks get on the floor and
give me 20.
very effective
never made it to youtube though
well you know it's never too late
so a couple of things real quick
the first is these exercises did you do
them
every day in the morning did you do them
midday
how many days a week at what time of day
so i almost always work out just after
lunch people always complain to me
that's like oh you'll get a sore stomach
or something i'm like but i don't never
happens
but i deliberately time it because i
have a real energy dip just after lunch
and so
doing something that's just not work
makes a ton of sense
yeah yeah plus after sitting for a few
hours you can break up the
two
marathons of sitting exactly and i'll
make one one other recommendation for
folks who may also
suffer from occasional or chronic
low back tightness which has been an
issue for me also if i sit a lot and it
ends up affecting my sleep most
significantly
and can cause that type of anterior
pelvic tilt
and
lordosis so if your gut is sticking out
and you look like you're fat or pregnant
even though you are not
perhaps that means your pelvis is is
pouring forward so if you think about
your pelvis as a goblet or a
cup full of water if you're pouring that
water out the front
you have anterior pelvic tilt
and
one of the causes of that or
contributing factors can be a really
tight
iliopsoas or iliacus that
then in some fashion
connects to the lower back the lumbar
and so you get this incredible tightness
slash pain for me it can cause tossing
and turning at night and really affect
my sleep
and the device that was recommended to
me a few times before i finally bit the
bullet and got it with something called
the so right pso hyphen r-i-t-e it is
the most expensive piece of plastic
you'll ever buy
but
worth it at something like 50-70
for self-release of the psoas which is
incredibly difficult to achieve i find
incredibly difficult to achieve by
yourself otherwise and most a lot of
soft tissue therapists are not
particularly good at helping with it
nor is it practical really didn't
necessarily have that type of work done
every day even if you could so the so
right is helpful all right so let's
let's move from
from personal long-termism
making sure that that you're able to
function and not be decrepit when you're
45
into the broader
the broader sense and
discussion of long-termism what is
long-termism and why did you write this
book
well long-termism is about three things
it's about taking seriously the sheer
scale
of the future that might be ahead of us
and just how high the stakes are in
anything that could shape that future
it's then about
trying to assess what the events that
might occur in our lifetimes that really
would have impact not just for the
present generation but they could
potentially shape the entire course of
humanity's future
and then thirds trying to figure out
like okay how do we
ensure that we can take actions to put
humanity onto the right path
and i think you'd exactly like to talk
about personal long-termism and the
analogy there because
in the book in what we are the future i
talk about
the analogy between
the pleasant world and humanity and an
implodent teenager like a reckless
teenager aware there are things you know
what really high stakes decisions that a
teenager makes it's like not what you do
at a weekend instead it's the sort of
it's the decisions that would impact the
entire course of your life
so in the book i you know tell a story
where i was quite a reckless teenager i
nearly killed myself climbing up a
building that was one of the biggest
decisions
dumbest decisions like i ever made
because if i had died then
it would have been
60 70 years of life that i would have
lost
in the same way if humanity dies now you
know if we cause although an extinction
or the end of uncoverable end of
civilization such as by a worst-case
pandemic
then we're losing
well not just 70 years of life it's
thousands millions even billions of
years of future civilization
and so similarly if
you know
i made decisions as a teenager that
affected the kind of whole course of my
life like whether to become a poet or a
philosopher or something you know i
could have become a doctor and similarly
i think in the coming essentially in our
lifetime
humanity potentially makes decisions
about you know how is future society
structured what the values we live by
is society
a liberal democracy around the world or
you know is it a totalitarian state
and
how do we handle technologies like ai
that i think could impact the very very
long run
so i want to read just a paragraph that
you sent me
which
i found thought provoking because it's a
framing that i had not heard before
and
here goes
imagine the entire human story from the
first homo sapiens of east africa to our
eventual end
represented as a single life where in
that life do we stand we can't know for
sure but suppose humanity lasted only a
tenth as long as the typical mammalian
species even then more than 99 percent
of this life would lie ahead on the
scale of a typical life humanity today
would just be six months old
but we might well survive even longer
for hundreds of millions of years until
the earth is no longer habitable or far
beyond in that case humanity is
experiencing its first blinking moments
out of the womb
and
i appreciated this framing
because
my feeling at least with
my audience of listeners
is that there's a small percentage who
are rushing headlong into battle with
some vision of long-termism and feel
committed
to fighting the good fight
and a non-trivial percentage
have decided it's too late right they've
decided that
the the end is nigh
we are the frog
in the water slowly heating that will be
boiling before we know it and
i find this at least
whether we put aside for the second how
people might
find fault with it or pick at it a a
useful counter frame right just to even
sit with
for
a few minutes
why do you think it's important to at
least
consider that something like this is
plausible maybe it's not ninety percent
likely but let's just say it's even
ten percent twenty percent likely
well it's so important just because
future generations matter future people
matter
and whatever you value
whether that's you know well-being or
happiness or maybe it's accomplishment
maybe it's great works of art maybe it's
scientific discovery
almost all of whatever you value would
be in the future rather than now
because the future just could be vast
indeed
where
you know again if you look at like what
was what has been accomplished
since the dawn of humanity well dawn of
humanity was the end a thousand years
ago
agriculture was 12 000 years ago
industrial revolution was 250 years ago
and yet
even on the scale of a typical mammal
species we have seven hundred thousand
years to go
now we're not typical mammal species we
could last only a few centuries we could
last 10 years if we really do ourselves
in
in the short term but we could last much
longer
and that just means that
all of what we might achieve
all of the good things that humanity
could produce
they're basically in the future and
that's really worth thinking about
taking seriously and trying to protect
and promote
you know one thing that you and i were
chatting a bit about i brought it up
before we start talking is
the question of is if it is possible to
make
let's just call it altruism or in this
case long-termism right investing in a
future we will not necessarily most
likely see ourselves
can you make that
self-interested or how do you position
it such that it appeals to
the greatest number of people possible
since our collective destiny depends on
some critical mass of people taking it
seriously right it can't probably isn't
one person
we're not going to get say 9 billion
people so
how many
do we
hope
to embrace this philosophy
and is it possible to position it as
self-interested and this is going to be
a bit of a ramble so i apologize in
advance but
when you were talking about
dostoyevsky and
nihilism almost as a proof and him
ultimately landing on god like yeah you
kind of need to something resembling god
to
sort of make sense of this sea of
uncertainty so that you can
maybe stabilize oneself and feel a sense
of meaning it brought to mind something
i read very recently and i apologize
this is again going to be a bit of
meander but
this is something that
russ roberts included so famous for econ
talk podcast
in an article he wrote called my 12
rules for life now he is
not sure this is the best descriptor but
culturally and i would think religiously
jewish so he has
that as a sort of lattice work of sorts
but number two in his 12 rules for life
was find something healthy to worship
and i'm just going to take a second to
read this he quoted david foster wallace
and and i'm gonna tie this into what i
just said in a second
because here's something else that's
weird but true in the day-to-day
trenches of adult life there's actually
no such thing as atheism there's no such
thing as not worshiping everybody
worships the only choice we get is what
to worship and the compelling reason for
maybe choosing some sort of god or
spiritual type of thing to worship be it
jc or allah be it
y h
w h not sure what that is or the wicked
mother goddess or the four noble truths
or some inviolable set of ethical
principles that is that pretty much
everything else you worship will eat you
alive if you worship money and things if
they are where you tap real meaning and
life then you'll never have enough never
feel you have enough
it's the truth worship your body and
beauty and sexual allure and you'll
always feel ugly and when time and age
start showing you will die a million
deaths before they finally grieve you on
one level we all know this stuff already
it's been codified as myths proverbs
cliches epigrams parables the skeleton
of every great story the whole trick is
keeping the truth up front and daily
consciousness
okay and then
but the most important thing to remember
is not to worship yourself not as easy
as it sounds so i'm wondering if
long-termism
in a sense
doesn't need to
be spun
to
envelop self-interest if it is basically
something to worship
it gives you purpose when there is so
much uncertainty
and
chaos and entropy
around us anyway long ted talk thank you
for coming but
what are your thoughts on on any of that
and the the the overarching question is
how do we make
long-termism
catch right yeah to
have some critical mass of people who
who really embrace it
i think there's a really important
insight there
actually one made by
john stuart mill in a speech to
parliament at the end of the 19th
century
and he asked this question like what
should we do for posterity after all
what has possibility ever done for us
and then actually he makes the argument
like perseverance has done a lot of
things for us because the projects we
have only have meaning insofar as
we think that they might contribute to
this kind of relay race among the
generations
here's a thought experiment there's this
film children of men
and in it people just unable to
reproduce
and so it's not that anyone dies there's
no you know
catastrophe that kills everybody but
there's no future of human civilization
you know how would that change your life
and i think for many many people and
many many projects it would just look
robbed of those projects of meaning
i certainly wouldn't be as nearly as
interested in
you know intellectual pursuits
or like trying to do good things and so
on i mean maybe i would to some extent
but
for a lot of things it seems like oh
they have meaning because you know take
scientific inquiry
there is this semi-built cathedral of
knowledge that has i've inhabited from
all of my ancestors
that has then been passed to us and it
is incomplete so we've got gender
relativity and we've got quantum theory
and they're amazing but we also know
they're incomplete and like maybe we can
work harder and like see father and
build the cathedral a little higher
but
if it's like no actually it'll just get
torn up
it's kind of like oh you're painting an
artwork and you can add to the painting
a bit and like it's gonna just go in the
shredder the day afterwards
you're not gonna be very motivated to do
it
and so
one thing i think that a lot of people
find motivating
is
yeah this thought that you're part of
this grand project much much grander
than yourself of trying to build a good
and flourishing
society
over the course of
not just centuries but thousands of
years
and that's one way in which our lives
have meaning
so what do you hope the
effect will be of people
or on people who read what we are the
future what are you hoping
some of the things will be that they
take from that
the number one thing is just
a world view that's
what my colleague nick boston calls
getting the big picture roughly light
so there are just so many problems that
the world faces today so many things you
could be focusing on and paying
attention to
but there's this question just well
what's most
important
what should be taking most of our
attention
and
this the ideas in the book i hope give a
partial answer which is
well
the things that most important are those
that really shape the long-term future
of the human project and that really
narrows things down i think
so that's kind of broad kind of world
view more specifically though
i would like it to be something that
guides the decisions people make over
the course of their lives so i think the
biggest decision people make are what
can they early pursue so do you go and
you know become a management consultant
or a financier and make money and
live in the suburbs or do you instead
like pursue a life that's really trying
to make the world better and if so then
what problems are you focusing on
where
it seems to me some of the biggest
problems are
the development of very advanced or the
biggest other issues or events that
occur in our lifetime are the
development of advanced artificial
intelligence in particular artificial
intelligence that's
as smart as humans or maybe considerably
smarter i think that has a good claim to
being
one of the most important technological
discoveries of all time once we get to
that point at that point
very good chances in the coming decades
a second is the risk of
west of you know very catastrophic
pandemics things that make
far worse than covert 19 which again i
think are just on the horizon because of
development in our ability to create new
viruses
and a third is a third world war
which again if you look at history
and look at leading scholars underlying
models of war uh i think it's like a
really pretty good chance we see a third
world war in our lifetime something like
one in three
and i think that could quite plausibly
have just unparalleled
dysfunction and misery on the world
in the limit just being the
end of civilization whether that's
because of
you know nuclear warheads scaling up a
hundredfold and being used in all that
nuclear war or because of the use of bio
weapons
and these are all things that like
like smart people who read this book
could go and work on
i'm aware that again kind of sounds
kind of bleak but uh perhaps the final
thing is like there is this positive
vision in the book too which is that if
we avoid these
threats or like manage these
technological transitions well we really
can just create a future that's truly
amazing and
i
you know this is pleasant kind of
throughout the book i did feel like
i
hadn't fully given it as due so there's
a little easter egg in the book as well
right in the final page qr code that
sketches a little vision of a positive
future
in short story form but maybe that's the
final thing of all in terms of this
world view is appreciating there's so
much at stake
there are enormous risks that we face or
threats that we face that we need to
manage but if we do then we can create a
world that is
flourishing and vibrant and wonderful
for our grandkids for their grandkids
for their grandkids
what is value lock-in and could you give
some historical examples
so value lock-in is when a single
ideology or value system or kind of set
of ideologies
kind of takes control of an area or in
the limit the whole world and then
persists for an extremely long time
and
this is one thing that i think can have
very very long lasting effects
and we've already seen it throughout
history and so in the
in what we are the future
i give a story of ancient china
so during this period that's known as
the hundred schools of thought the zhu
dynasty had fallen
and there was a like a lot of
fragmentation like ideological
fragmentation in china and wandering
philosophers would go from state to
state with a package of kind of
philosophical ideas and moral views and
political
policy recommendations and try and
convince like political elites of their
ideas
and there were four main schools
there were the confucians that were kind
of most familiar with
the legalists which are kind of like
machiavellian like political realists
um just you know how do you get power
was the main focus of them
taoists who are these kind of
more
somewhat more spiritual like acting in
accordance with the way with nature like
advocating spontaneity honesty
and then finally the moests which i read
and i'm like wow they were kind of
similar to the effect of like effective
altruists except in ancient china
where they were about promoting good
outcomes and good outcomes impartially
considered
they
forwent
much like fancy kind of spending on
luxury or ritual so their funeral rights
were very
modest they wore very modest clothes
and they were just really concerned
about trying to make the world better
and so they created a power military
group in order to defend cities that
were under siege
where the reasoning being that if
defensive technology and defensive
strategy was so good then no one could
ever wage a war because no one could
ever win
and so there was this great diversity of
thought but what happened one state
within china the chin
influenced by legalism took over
and tried to
try to essentially make
legalism
state orthodoxy and the emperor chin
declared himself a 10 000 year emperor
wanted this ideology to persist
indefinitely it actually only lasted 14
years because there was a kind of
counter rebellion
and that was the start of the han
dynasty
which then successfully did
basically over the course of
a while
quell kind of other ideological
competition and instead
implemented confucianisms like this is
the official state ideology and that
persisted for 2000 years
and
that's kind of just one example among
many
over and over again you see
what's the kind of ideology or belief
set of ruling power
whether that's
christians or certainly i mean catholics
or protestants
or is it communism of the merely usual
of stalin or national socialism of
hitler
once that ideology gets into power
people with those ideology get into
power they quickly try and stomp out the
competition
and the worry is that could happen with
the entire world so again i spoke of a
risk of third world war
well what might happen as a result one
ideology could
take power globally after winning such a
war implement a world
of government or world state or at least
dominant world ideology
then we're in this situation where
there's much less ideological
competition
and at least one reason why we've gotten
moral change and model progress over
time which is in virtue of having a
diversity of moral views that are able
to like kind of fight it out in the in
ideal circumstances the kind of the best
argument wins we would no longer have
that
and so
if there was a single kind of dominant
ideology in the world that could persist
for an extremely long time i think
and if it was wrong which is quite
likely to be wrong because i think most
of our moral views are probably wrong
that would be like very bad indeed
yeah
i mean just to give you an idea i mean
this is not exactly ideological but you
mentioned the han
dynasty
and you know mandarin chinese one way to
say mandarin chinese is kanye which is
the language of the han people like like
is the romanization
system used which most people have seen
with the diacritical march for tones for
mandarin chinese so these things can
last a very long time indeed do you have
any other examples of
a value
lock-in that could be past tense
historical examples or attempts that are
being made currently that you think are
worth
making mention of could be either i mean
historically one particularly salient
example was uh when the khmer values
took power in cambodia
paul pott just very systematically like
anyone who disagreed with the kind of
party ideology
would be
i mean generally would just be executed
so 25 of the population were killed in
cambodia and i mean he again it's like
very transparent what's happening he has
this
quote purify the party purify the army
purify the cadres so it's just very
clear that's what going on is you know
almost like a
species or virus kind of taking over and
like other
competitors get wiped out this one
ideology takes over competitors are
wiped out
similarly if we look at like british
history with
at different times catholics and
protestants taking power there was one
act passed
called the act of uniformity
with
the protestants saying like okay
catholicism is now banned in this
country and again it's like very boldly
named and in general just if you have a
particular moral view then
you are going to want everyone else in
the world to have that particular model
view as well
so of ai
pathogens
let's just say
bio weapons we can include in that
world war three how would you rank those
for you personally in terms of
concern over the next
let's call it
let's call it 10 years
over the next 10 years i'd be most
concerned about ai
over the next 50 years let's say my
lifetime i'd be both most concerned
about
ai and war
development and ai the reason i say that
is like
wars are most likely when
two countries are very similar kind of
military power
and
the kind of historical rate of like one
country
going to war with an like one major
power in the world like one of the big
economies of the world going to war with
another when it kind of gets overtaken
economically
or militarily it's pretty high some ways
of modeling the size like 50
but i think that's more likely to happen
not kind of within the next 10 years
though it's definitely possible
that there would be some kind of
outbreak of war such as between the u.s
and china
even though the rescue war between the
us and russia is definitely higher than
it has been in the last
i guess 30 years potentially i still
think the odds are like quite low
thankfully
with ai on the other hand
i think
the chance of very rapid and
surprisingly rapid developments in ai
within the next 10 years are higher than
any 10-year point after that
so as in 2020s it's more likely there'll
be some truly transformative development
than 2030s 2040s is my kind of view and
that's for a couple of reasons one is
that if you look at like how much
computing power different
brains use
and you compare that with how much
computing power the kind of current
language models use or the biggest kind
of ai systems use
the biggest ai systems use the computing
power of approximately the brain of a
honey bee it's kind of hard to estimate
exactly but that's kind of where we are
which is a lot smaller than you might
think it's much smaller than i thought
and you might think like okay it's the
point in time where you've got ai
systems that are about as powerful as
human brains that's like a really
crucial moment in time
because that's you know potentially the
point in time at which
ai systems just become more powerful
than us or at least approximately then
when we start to get overtaken
and that
again it's like very uncertain but
there's a decent pretty good chance that
happens in something like 10 years time
and now it's very hard to do
technological prediction i am not making
any confident predictions about how
things go down
but it's at least something we should be
paying attention to
just from a kind of outside perspective
if you think oh yeah and then we're at
the point where we're like training
these ai systems that are like
doing as much computing as the brain is
that's like okay well at least maybe
they're going to be just you know of a
similar level of power and ability as
human beings and then that's really big
and that's kind of big for a few reasons
i think
one is because it could speed up dates
of technological discovery so
historically we've had like fairly
steady technologically delivering
economic growth that's actually over the
couple of hundred years
but that's because of two things
happening
one is that like ideas get progressively
harder to find but we throw more and
more researchers so we have like a
bigger population we throw a larger
percentage of the population at them
if instead we can just create engineers
and research scientists that are ai
systems
then we could rapidly increase the
amount of r d that's happening
and what's more
perhaps they'd be much much better at
doing the search than we are like
you know human brains are definitely not
designed for doing science
but we could create machines that really
are and in the same way that
you know go the best ai systems are far
far better than even the very best human
systems now the same could happen within
science and if you plug that into like
the standard economic models you get the
conclusion that
okay suddenly things start really moving
like really very fast
and you might get many centuries worth
of technological progress happening over
the course of a few years or a decade
and that could be terrific that's what a
lot of the
you know in a sense i think both the
kind of
the optimists and the doomsayers are
correct where that could be amazing if
it gets handled very well then it could
be radical abundance for everyone we
could solve all the other problems in
the world if it gets handled badly well
the course of that tech development
could be dangerous pathogens
yeah or it could enable us to lose
control to ai systems or it could be
involved like misuse by
humans themselves so i think and i can
go into that more but i think there's
just a lot of things going on that could
be extremely important from the
long-term perspective
well let's go into it more i mean i as a
as a simpleton assume that
pretty much any new technology is going
to be applied to porn and warfare first
and that those two will also
sort of reciprocally
drive forward a lot of new technology
i'm actually only ten percent joking
but go ahead well do you know dial e2
i do actually yes i'm gonna be using it
a bunch this week oh fantastic well
for listeners who don't know it's a
fairly recent
ai system
and you can tell it
to produce a certain image using text so
maybe that image is uh an astronaut
writing a unicorn
in space in the style of andy warhol
and it will create a near-perfect
rendition of that
and you can really say a lot of things
you can say oh i want a hybrid of a
dolphin and a horse riding on a unicycle
and it will just create a picture of
that it's really like in a way that
really makes it seem like it understands
the words you're telling it
and at the moment it can create like
non faces of
imaginary people almost picture perfect
again if you pay close attention you can
see like weird details so they kind of
give it away when you say imaginary
people what do you mean so if you type
in like a picture of boris johnson
then it will not give you a picture of
bothers johnson
and i don't know that's for sure but my
strong guess is that because that's
because it's been deliberately
restrained so that it does not do that
right because well so it doesn't deep
fake everything
exactly yeah because um you were
mentioning porn like
with that technology like
you could well
fill in the blanks i'll let you think of
your own text bumps that you could put
in
involving
you know joe biden or tim ferdis or
whoever you want joe biden and tim
ferriss oh yeah exactly brothers johnson
too you're all in the flame
who knew you were such good fans oh god
the horror the horror yeah
so to my knowledge that's not been used
for porn yet but um i think the
technology would make it completely
possible
and then is it going to be used for
warfare like absolutely i mean
there'll be a point in time when we can
automate
weaponly
so
at the moment part of the cost of going
to war is that your people part of your
population will die
that's also a check on
dictatorial leaders as well you need to
at least keep the army on your side
otherwise there'll be a military coup
now imagine if there's a world where the
army is entirely automated well
dictators can be much more reassured
because
they're their army can be entirely loyal
to them it's just coded in yeah also the
costs of going to war much lower as well
because
you're no longer sustaining casualties
on your own side
and so that's just one way in which
technological advances could be hugely
disruptive
via ai
and it's far from the biggest way
so let's take a
just a short
intermission from
skynet and world war three just for a
second and we're going to come back to
exploring some of those but
what are
some actual
long-termist projects
today that you are excited about
so one that i'm extremely excited about
is investment in and development of a
technology called
uh far uvc lighting
far uvc is just a very specific and
quite narrow spectrum of light
and with sufficient intensity
just put into light bulbs it seems like
that just sterilizes the room
now we don't we're not confident in this
yet we need
more research on its efficacy and our
safety but
if this was just installed in all
lighting in every house around the world
basically in the same way that we do for
fire regulation like every house at
least in a relatively well-off country
has to meet certain standards for fire
safety it could also have to meet
certain standards for disease safety
like
having light bulbs with uvc
light as part of them
then we could would make a very
substantial progress to never having a
pandemic again
as well as as a bonus of advocating all
the spirit to the disease
and so this is like some extremely
exciting technology there's a foundation
that i've been spending a lot of time
helping to
set up over the last six months
it's called future fund
and
this is something that like yeah we're
donating to and investing in
because yeah it just could make an
absolute transformative difference
so that's one other things that are very
concrete within the biotech space
include kind of early detection of new
pathogens so just constantly sampling
wastewater or constantly testing
healthcare workers and doing like full
spectrum diagnostics of like just all
the dna in the sample excluding human
dna like is there anything there that we
just
looks like a pathogen and we don't
understand
so that we can kind of react to new
pandemics fairly quickly
also more boringly just like better ppe
where you could just have you know you
put on your super ppe hood and you're
now just completely protected from any
sorts of pathogens that could enable
society to continue even if there was an
outbreak of a really bad pandemic
so that's very exciting within biotech
within ai there's a lot of work on
technical ai safety
where the idea is just
using methods to
ensure the ai systems do what we want
them to do
where
you know that means
even if they're very powerful not
trying to seek power and disempower the
people who uh created them
not being deceptive
not causing harm
and there are various things you can do
there including with these kind of you
know not as sophisticated models that
we're currently using like tests to see
if they are acting deceptively what are
structures you can use to make them not
act deceptively can we
have better interpretability so that we
actually understand what the hell is
going on with these ai models because at
the moment they're very non-transparent
and we really don't know like what's
how do they get to a particular answer
it's just this huge like huge
computational process
where we've like trained it via learning
over
what in computer time is like extremely
long time so maybe it's like
tens of thousands or even millions of
games of go that's played and now it's
like very good at go but like what's the
reasoning that's going on we don't
really know
we could keep going as well there's just
like many many things within technical
ai safety
and then there's the governance side of
things both for ai for other
technologies reducing the risk of world
war three here i kind of admit it gets
tough it's like very hard to
measure and be confident that we're
doing stuff that's
like actively good and we have to hope a
little bit more that just
having smart thoughtful competent people
in positions of
you know political influence where
they're able to like
understand the arguments on both sides
and put in
policies and regulation in place
such that like we more carefully
navigate
these big technological advances or such
that we don't go to war
or face some sort of race dynamic
between different countries that is also
just like extremely important to me in
my view
okay let me take a
pause to jump back to
a number of the questions i have
next to me
when you feel
overwhelmed or unfocused
or if you feel you've lost your focus
temporarily what do you do
you know the questions you ask yourself
activities because i think it is easy
maybe i'll just speak for myself to feel
like there's so much
potentially coming down the pike that is
an existential threat
it's easiest just to
curl up into
the fetal position and
just scroll through tick tock or
instagram and pretend like it isn't
coming
not saying that is where you end up but
when you feel overwhelmed or unfocused
or under focused what do you do
for me it's most often driven by
you know developing my mood yeah so i've
had issues with depression since forever
basically although now it just is far
far better like i think i normally say
i'm something like five to ten times
happier than i was a decade ago
it's pretty good that is good we were
happy about that yeah
and so i have a bit of
have you heard of the term of a trigger
action plan
say that one more time
i'm not sure if there's the word or the
scottish accent i know it's a trigger
action plan
oh my god i have shrek on the podcast
this is amazing all right yeah trigger
action plan go ahead exactly so no i
don't know what that is the idea is
there's a trigger like some event that
you hit
that happens and it's just like when
that event happens you immediately just
put into place some action so
a fire alarm goes off then it's like
everyone knows what to do there's the
fire drill
you follow the fire devil you like stand
up you walk outside you leave your
belongings and it's like it's so you
don't have to think in complex
situations
i do that but for when i have like low
mood the thing that's been very bad in
the past is when it's like oh i've got
low mood so i'm not being as effective
and productive so i'm going to have to
work even harder and therefore i beat
myself up and it makes even worse
so instead what i do is i'm just like if
i notice my mood is really slumping and
therefore it's like harder to work i
just bump like fix my mood to like top
of my to-do list
becomes like the most important priority
where the crucial thing is not to let it
spiral
the number one thing i do is just i go
to the gym or go for the run
because then i'm like look i want to do
this a certain amount of time per week
anyway it's something i enjoy i find
like recreation so
worst case i'm just moving time around
similarly i'll probably meditate as well
then at the same time in terms of how i
think i have again certain kind of
cached thoughts that i found very
helpful so one is just thinking about
how it's like yep this happens before
and it's not the end of the world it's
been okay
like
if i've you know gone through this
before it's just i'll be able to get
through it again probably
second is just
thinking about
no longer assessing like the individual
day that i'm having
but instead some like larger chunk of
time yeah where it's easy to beat
yourself up if you're like look i've had
just the shittest day and i've done
nothing what a loser
whereas if you're like okay well how
have i done over the last three years
or 10 years or like my whole life
and
at least assuming you feel kind of okay
about that
uh which i do then it's that's very
reassuring it's like okay
i've had a [ __ ] day but like if someone
were to write a history of my last few
years they probably wouldn't talk about
this day they talk about the other
things and so it's kind of like
i've got a little bit in the bank there
so even if i just take the whole day off
like in the grand scheme of things it
doesn't really matter
and so some of these thoughts then
you know that combined with like taking
a bit of time away from whatever's
making me plunge
and then like exercise i just find has a
mood boost as well
so also but then also gives time for
these thoughts to really percolate and
sink in
generally means that i can just then
like come back a couple of hours later
and be pretty refreshed
but the key thing is just like once this
happens you just you just do the thing
and you stop thinking it's like look
this is what my plan is
can you say trigger action planned one
more time in a heavy scottish accent
take an action plan that's what you need
power
i'm gonna put that right at the
podcast
oh so good so good uh thank you thank
you
for that
you know if this uh long-term effective
altruism philosophy thing doesn't work
out for you i think you have a future in
voice acting so you always have that
effective autism is about doing the most
count you can
not being a wee girl's blouse
i don't know what if you speak in
scottish accent suddenly you've got to
be
somewhat aggressive and like insulting
someone otherwise it doesn't quite work
you can't whisper an aggressive scottish
accent it's very hard yeah exactly very
very challenging i'm not even going to
try that it would be embarrassing but
let's let's hop back into ai for a
moment so you hang out with
the a lot of the smart cool kids
and very technical people who really
understand this stuff
when
they talk about
robots gone bad
or just the plausible
scenarios that would be
very bad
what are they like what are the two or
three things that they would see
as a
an event
or development
that would sort of be the equivalent of
the trigger action plan right where it's
like oh this is life before in life
after what are these say two or three or
one to three scenarios
that
they've honed in on
from my perspective two extremely
worrying scenarios one is
that ai
systems get just much more powerful than
human systems and they have goals that
are misaligned with human goals
and
they
realize that
human beings are standing away of them
achieving their goals
and so they
take control and perhaps that means they
just like wipe everyone out perhaps they
don't even need to so an analogy is
often given between
like the lies of homo sapiens from the
perspective of the chimpanzees
where
homo sapiens were just smarter they were
able to work together they just had
these advantages
and that just means the chimpanzees just
have very little say in how things go
over the long term basically no say
it's not that we made them extinct
although in a sense they're kind of
lucky we made many you know in fact i
think we made most of large animals
extinct due to the lives of homo sapiens
but that could happen with ai as well we
could be
to the ai systems what chimpanzees are
to humans or perhaps it's actually more
extreme because once you've got air
systems that are smarter than you and
they're building air systems that are
smarter again maybe it's more like
we're like ants looking at humans
when we're looking at advanced ai
systems
so give me the second one and then i'm
gonna come back to the first one with
just a sci-fi thought experiment for
sure
and then the second one is like okay
even assume that we
do manage to align
air systems with human goals so we can
really get them to do whatever they want
nonetheless this could be a very scary
thing
where
if you do think that ai systems could
lead to much faster rates of
technological progress
for in particular by you know automating
technological discovery including the
creation of better ai systems see like
we've got ai writing the code that
builds the next generation of ai that
then writes even better codes build the
next generation of ai things could
happen like very quickly
well even if you manage to
have ai systems do exactly what you want
them to do
well that could concentrate power in
you know a very small number of hands
could be a
single country could be a company it
could be like an individual within a
single country who wants to instill a
dictatorship
and then
once you've got that power
with an it's kind of similar to what
happened during the industrial
revolution and earlier so
you have got more and more powerful
technology over that period and what did
it do it used it to
you know colonize and subjugate a very
large faction of the world
in the same way it could happen but even
faster a small group gets such power and
use it to
essentially take over the world
and then once it's in power well once
you've got ai systems
i think you're able to have
indefinite social control in a way
that's like very worrying and this is
value lock-in again
where at the limit imagine you're kind
of the dictator of a totalitarian state
like 1984 or the handmaid's tale or
something
and that's a global totalitarian state
and you really want your ideology
to persist forever
well you can pass that ideology on to
this
ai successor it just says like yep you
go all the world now and the ai has no
need to die it's like software it can
replicate itself indefinitely so
unlike dictators
who will die off eventually causing a
certain amount of change to occur well
this is not true for the ai it could
replicate itself indefinitely and it
could be like in every area of society
and so then when you've got that it's
like why would we expect moral change
after that point
and it's like
kind of hard to see
so in general i think there can be these
states where
you get into a particular state of the
world and you just kind of can't get out
of it again
and this kind of orwellian perpetual
like totalitarianism is actually one of
the things i really worry about
okay first question again this is a
happy book it's an update
[Laughter]
uh
so
yes so so within the context of our
discussion of the happy book
you talked about i think it was the
moests i can't remember the term you
used but you mentioned they were similar
to effective altruism and they formed a
paramilitary group when are you forming
the effective altruism paramilitary
group
counter ai insurgency squad
is that in the works well there is an
analogy between
we haven't yet we haven't yet got our
own army probably that won't happen i
think things are going pretty weird if
they have and i might need to intervene
at that point
but there is an analogy where
you know they built very powerful and
created very good defensive technology
so you know you've got trebuchet is very
powerful for attacking you say trebuchet
trebuchets oh trebuchet yeah it's like a
catapult what is that it's got a sling
on it is that what it is it's like a
catapult with a sling so you get the uh
it's like an atlatl but for throwing
much bigger things anyway the physics
involved i think the same yeah
for sure but you know also walls are
defensive technology if you had just
really good walls really good defenses
then i thought you said wolves for a
second i was like wow i did not
did not see that coming
have to resurrect the wolf if we want to
have any hope of defensive wolf
technology all right walls yeah
they are training eagles to attack
drones so it's not like it's not so
insane
yeah
all right
wolves to attack the robot overlords i
don't back the wolves i've got to say
[Laughter]
but we can think in the same terms of
look there's certain technology that has
kind of offensive advantage so the
ability to design new pathogens there's
certain technology that's like has a
defensive advantage like this far uvc
radiation
and so one of the things we're doing is
really trying to develop and speed speed
up kind of defensive technology
and so similarly when you look at ai
there's some things that just pure
capabilities it's just ai getting more
and more powerful and then there are
some things that are
helpful in making sure that ai is safe
like understanding what's under the hood
of these models
um just means that like okay we know
what's going on a bit better we can like
use it better we can predict what sort
of behavior they'll have
okay so let's let's talk about defensive
capabilities i'll just give another
example of an asymmetric
offense defense situation which would be
drone warfare right so the ability to
create
weaponized
potentially lethal
drones and swarms and so on is much
lower than the cost to defend against
them generally speaking right i mean
certainly that becomes true if you start
to combine
say
targeted bioweapons with drones things
get really expensive too at the at best
to defend against but let's let's talk
about my sci-fi scenario sure so
when you use the
analogies of humans and chimps or the
analogy of the industrial revolution and
the technological gains in western
europe predominantly which then allowed
the
physical and that's the word all
underscore sort of subjugation and
colonization and dominance of a
significant percentage of the world's
population
i suppose there's part of me that on a
simplistic level it feels like even
though this would not be easy to do
because it would be sort of like a
homicide suicide for a lot of folks the
more interdependent we become but it's
like all right if ai is constrained to
a
to physical infrastructure that is
dependent upon power
would not part of the defensive
planning or preemptive planning go into
trying to restrict
ai
to something that can be unplugged to
put it really simply
but how are people playing out this
hypothetical scenario right so with the
ai
presumably if it's as smart or smarter
than we are foresee this and then
develop sort of solar-powered extensions
of itself so
it can do a b and c i mean
how are people i'm sure this is part of
the conversation i've just never had it
so what are what are smarter people
exploring with respect to this type of
stuff
yeah your nose is pointed in a good
direction on this one
and it's this sort of thing that makes
me
among my peers on the more optimistic
end of thinking that
advanced ai would not kill everybody
where yeah you could have like
air-gapped computers so you can't access
the internet now that don't have other
ways of kind of controlling the world
apart from kind of text output
and they have been trained to act as
kind of articles
so they are just you just ask them a
question and they give you
ideally like very justified connect to
answer
and perhaps you have many of these as
well you've got like a dozen of them and
they don't know that the others exist
and then you just start asking them for
help so you're like okay we're going to
start building these like incredibly
powerful ai systems they're much much
smarter and more generally able than we
are like what should we do what should
our plan be
and so that's a pathway where it's like
you're using ai to help solve the
problems
that
we will face with even more powerful ai
and what's the response
i mean some people would say oh well if
the ai systems are really that powerful
they're like far better than humans
they will then fix you
so and they'll be able to do that just
by outputting text and telling you like
oh do this thing or do this thing
and that will all be this like long
deceptive play and i just think that's
unlikely that just seems to be expected
for me i don't have like strong reasons
to think that we would have that
the current ai systems we have are more
like
you know they just output text it's not
like they're an agent that's like trying
to do things in the world you just put
in the text in input it gives you a text
output at least for language models and
potentially we can scale that up
to the point where
they're
yeah like these kind of sages and boxes
and i think like so i think that's a
significant pathway by which like we
make
even more powerful um ai systems that
are kind of agentic are kind of acting
you know have a model of the world and
trying to do things in the world that we
make them safe
but that's exactly a good example of um
yeah again kind of differential
technological progress where
an ai system that's just like this
article in a box
you know separated from the rest of the
world that seems very good from a
defensive perspective
whereas an ai system that's been trained
on like war games
and then it's just like the least into
the open seems like potentially very bad
oh yes indeed
robot's gone wild
all right
are you going to create a new subreddit
i don't know if i'll create a subreddit
i mean i'm i'm tempted to start digging
spider holes in my backyard and learning
how to hunt with bow and arrow yeah but
you know all things in due time
what are the most important actions
people can take
now
all right what are some actions for
people who are like i want to be
an agent of change i want to feel some
locus of
if not control at least free will
i don't want to just
lay on my back and wait for
the cyborg raptors to descend upon me or
to become a house pet for some dictator
in a foreign land who overtakes the u.s
as a superpower or whatever it is right
i want to actually do something what
what are some of the
most important or maybe impactful
actions that that people can take
so i think there's kind of two pathways
for such a person
one you might be motivated to help but
you don't really want to
reject your whole life
ideally perhaps you just don't really
want to have to think about this again
but you do want to be doing good
then i think the option of donations is
just particularly good so you could take
the given what we can pledge you make a
10 donation every year of your income
and then you can give to somewhere like
the long-term future fund that's part of
ea funds and it'll get redistributed to
what some
kind of domain experts think of the
highest impact things to do in this
space that's the kind of like baseline
response or something and i think it's
important to emphasize you can do an
enormous amount of good there you know
there's a lot of ways we could spend
money to do good things in the world
including from this long-term
perspective
the second is if you're like no actually
i want to
yeah be more actively a kind of agent of
change
then i think the first thing to do is to
learn more you know i've tried to pack
as much as i can into a book but
i think is yeah there's a lot to engage
with i mean
the book is what we are the future you
know it's talking about some big
philosophical ideas it's also just
covering a lot of a broad ground of
different disciplines different issues
like you know we talked about ai and
technology and
biowsk and world war three there's
plenty of other issues i didn't talk
about we haven't talked about nukes we
haven't talked about technological
stagnation which i think is particularly
important as well we also haven't talked
even just about promoting better values
as well kind of or more broad ways of
making the long term better
so all of these things are things that i
think we can learn
and
therefore i would encourage leading the
precipice by toby ord which i mentioned
in my recommended books
also eighty thousand hours.org as well
has enormous amounts of content
openphilanthropy.org
also has just a lot of really
interesting content they're a foundation
but they've done some really deep
research into some of these topics such
as this issue which we didn't get to
touch of when we should expect
human level intelligence to arise with
some arguments that
you know we should really put a lot of
probability mass like maybe more than 50
on it coming in the next few decades
and then following that i think the most
important single decision is how can you
either
use or leverage your career or switch
career in order to work on some of these
you know most important issues and again
we've really tried to make this as easy
as possible by providing like endless
online advice and also like one-on-one
coaching such that people can yeah get
advice
and then the final thing would be
getting involved with the effect of
altruism community where this stuff is
hard it can be intimidating
one of the big things that just is a
fact when we start thinking about
these more kind of civilizational scale
issues compared to
the kind of original cwa which is
you know funding these very well
evidenced programs that demonstrably
improve health is like it can be very
overwhelming and
it can be hard to know exactly how to
fit in but we now have a community of
thousands or tens of thousands of people
who are working together and really keen
to help each other
and there are many conferences like ea
global
conferences places like london dc san
francisco all kind of independently
organized conferences ea global x's
in many places there'll be one in india
for example in early january
as well as like hundreds of local groups
around the world where people get
together and you know
can often like provide support and help
each other try and figure out like okay
what is the most impactful thing you can
do
so yeah that would be my kind of laundry
list of advice
with respect to say
ditching the news or at least going on a
lower information diet with the most
manufactured
urgency that we get flooded with instead
spending time
looking at big picture trends or trying
to get that big picture roughly right as
you put it both from a historical
perspective and a current perspective
would you still recommend
for podcasts in our time hosted by
melvin bragg
i believe discusses history philosophy
science with leading academics and the
80 000 hours podcast
would those be two you would still
recommend yeah i would still strongly
recommend them there's also another
podcast here this idea by finn morehouse
and luca regatti
i also particularly like rationally
speaking by julia gaylef as well
it's like very good
and then in terms of websites if you
want like big picture
like beyond the websites i've already
said
to just have like the best big picture
understanding of the world i don't know
of a single better source than our world
and data
which is just i mean it was very
influential during the covert pandemic
but it has
you know if you want to learn about
nuclear war or long-run economic growth
or world population it's articles that
are presenting
both data and like the best
understanding of the data
in just this like timeless evergreen way
with exceptional vigor and exceptional
depth it's just it's just amazing i use
it very heavily to like
orient myself for the book
so will mccaskill
people can find you on twitter at will
mccaskill m-a-c-a-s-k-i-l-l
on the web william mccaskill dot com the
new book is what we owe the future i
recommend people check it out is there
anything else you would like to
add any
requests to the audience anything you'd
like to point people to any
complaints or grievances with this
podcast process you would like to air
publicly anything at all that you'd like
to add before we
wrap this conversation up
the main thing to say is just like as
we've said over and over again i think
like we face truly enormous challenges
in our life many of these challenges are
very scary they can be overwhelming they
can be intimidating
but i really believe that each of us
individually can make an enormous
difference to these problems we really
can significantly help as part of a
wider community to putting humanity onto
a better path and if we do then
the future really could be long and
absolutely flourishing and your great
grandkids will thank you
well thank you very much well i always
enjoy our conversations and i appreciate
the time ditto thanks so much tim
absolutely and to everybody listening i
will link to all the resources and the
books and websites and so on in the show
notes as per usual item.blog podcast
and until next time be just a little bit
kinder than necessary and thanks for
tuning in
you